[Musique]
et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
Carole Delga bonjour Carole delgat merci
beaucoup d'être avec nous présidente
socialiste de la région Occitanie
présidente de région de France et vous
êtes avec nous en duplex depuis
Saint-Malo en Bretagne où se tient le
congrès de région de France dont on va
parler dans quelques secondes mais
d'abord je voudrais vous faire réagir à
l'information de cette nuit c'était
Elisabeth borne qui a déclenché une
nouvelle fois le 49-3 sur la loi de
programmation de finances publiques
c'est le premier texte de la saison
est-ce qu'elle avait autre chose la
première ministre selon vous
bonjour non elle n'avait pas d'autre
choix donc on savait qu'elle allait
avoir recours au 49-3 c'était une
évidence le gouvernement n'a pas de
majorité et n'a pas réussi à convaincre
donc une majorité de députés pour voter
cette loi de programmation donc vous
comprenez ce choix vous ne le contestez
pas
ce choix et c'est une évidence parce
qu'il n'y a pas la capacité du
gouvernement à créer une majorité c'est
regrettable que il n'y est pas plus de
souplesse plus de sens du collectif plus
de conviction de la part du gouvernement
mais personne n'était surpris avec les
positions du gouvernement sur l'issue
d'un recours au 49-3
qui va venir à Saint-Malo pour clôturer
votre congrès des régions de France ce
matin qu'est-ce que vous attendez de la
première ministre
mais nous attendons tout d'abord qu'elle
puisse enfin comprendre qu'elle a tout
intérêt à avoir un travail en commun
entre l'État et les régions pour
atteindre les objectifs de la
planification écologique pour atteindre
les objectifs de mobilité qui soit moins
cher qui soit plus des carbonées pour
atteindre les objectifs de souveraineté
industriels l'État et les régions
doivent travailler ensemble et donc
l'État a besoin de nous comme nous nous
avons besoin de l'État et donc c'est un
message de faire confiance aux régions
parce que ça soit dans le projet de loi
de finance il y a une baisse
significative des moyens financiers des
régions mais il y a également la mise en
oeuvre de différentes réformes qui vont
une fois de plus donner plus de pouvoir
à la technocratie et moins d'agilité sur
les décisions locales mais le message
est important car enlever le gars mais
j'imagine que vous attendez des actes de
la première ministre qu'est-ce qu'elle
doit vous dire qu'est-ce qu'elle doit
vous annoncer pour que vous sortiez
satisfaite de ce congrès
non mais tout d'abord nous les
présidents et les présidents de région
on est proactif c'est-à-dire c'est nous
qui allons faire des propositions vous
avez entendu les déclarations du
président de la République un coup
c'était 100 milliards d'euros pour
l'instant il n'y a pas un seul euro de
concret un autre coup c'est le Pass à 49
euros pour les trains donc nous les
présidents et les présidents région nous
allons proposer à la première ministre
qui est des Assises de la mobilité
ferroviaire qui vont porter et sur le
financement de l'investissement et sur
la question de la tarification donc
c'est une méthode de travail très
pragmatique qui permet de répondre aux
attentes de nos concitoyens nous les
paroles commencent vraiment à être
enflot un peu trop important et il
manque en effet des preuves donc la
clairement des Assises nationales qui
après pourront être aussi décliné
régionalement mais sur la mobilité
ferroviaire il faut complètement revoir
le mode de financement et le
sous-investissement sur le rail nous
avons un des réseaux ferrés les plus
vieux d'Europe depuis des années l'État
français sous investi en Allemagne c'est
trois fois plus que en France donc nous
allons vraiment être sur un
investissement massif mais également une
tarification qui soit attractive on veut
être pas cher elle a promis un New Deal
du ferroviaire c'est pas suffisant pour
vous
oui à la promis comme vous dites vous
dites elle a promis mais aujourd'hui
dans les négociations qu'on ne menons
dans les contrats de plan état région il
n'est pas à la hauteur de ce qui a été
indiqué effectivement beaucoup de
questions sur les transports vous avez
rencontré Clément Bonnières
le ministre des Transports oui tout à
fait nous avons eu une réunion de
travail entre tous les présidents de
région et le ministre des Transports
nous avons en effet conclu qu'il était
nécessaire d'avoir cet engagement
national beaucoup plus fort c'est séance
de travail et nous avons donc programmé
plusieurs réunions mais c'est pour ça
que nous les présidents région nous
tendons la main à la première ministre
où nous lui disons travaillons ensemble
sur les mobilités de façon concrète
passons des annonces qui sont vides de
sens à une réalité pour nos concitoyens
travaillant aussi sur la question de la
planification écologique sur la
souveraineté industrielle il faut
vraiment enclencher une nouvelle
dynamique et aujourd'hui les Français
ils sont là ils sont fatigués d'avoir
des annonces qui ne sont pas suivies des
faits il faut donner des solutions au
pouvoir d'achat qui est de plus en plus
faible pour nos compatriotes et
également des solutions pour une
transformation écologique qui soit
vraiment forte sur l'écologie pour faire
le lien également avec les transports
parmi les annonces de la feuille d'euros
de la planification écologique et une
enveloppe de 700 millions d'euros pour
13 RER métropolitain est-ce que vous
êtes satisfaite de cette annonce est-ce
que là on est dans la bonne échelle
non on n'est pas dans la bonne échelle
mais on va pas être dans la critique
permanente parce que c'est une évidence
les 13 RER métropolitain c'est plus de
10 milliards d'euros vous comprenez que
700 millions ça veut dire que ça va
financer une partie des études pour les
5 prochaines années parce que là on
parle pour les 5 prochaines années d'une
petite dizaine de projets sur les
métropoles mais là il faut ne pas être
dans une bataille de chiffres parce que
nous avons une urgence écologique nous
avons une urgence sociale et nous avons
une urgence républicaine si on continue
à être dans la petite phrase si on
continue à faire des annonces qui ne se
pas suivies des faits c'est la
République qui est en danger donc là il
faut amener des preuves des solutions
concrètes à nos concitoyens et c'est
l'état d'esprit des présidents de région
soyons dans le fer soyons dans la
solution et arrêtons d'être dans
l'incantation ou dans les promesses non
tenues un dernier mot sur Clément bonne
il a annoncé l'arrêt de plusieurs
projets autoroutiers mais il continue de
défendre le projet d'as69 l'autoroute
entre Castres et Toulouse dans votre
région est-ce qu'il vous a rassuré
alors il nous a en effet indiqué pour
que pour cette autorité il y avait la
continuité les autres projets qu'il
envisage d'arrêter ne sont pas connus
mais je rappelle que le sud du Tarn
c'est un territoire qui est très pauvre
c'est un taux de chômage qui est
supérieur à 50% à la moyenne c'est un
taux de pauvreté supérieur de 40 %.
voilà c'est un territoire qui perd de la
population et on a besoin d'action
l'autoroute n'est pas la seule solution
mais c'est une des conditions du
désenclavement et surtout j'appelle
celles et ceux qui font la grève de la
faim à stopper parce que ça c'est un
préalable aucun projet ne mérite la mise
en danger des vies que de sur ces
écologistes projets nous devons être
constructifs vous les comprenez ces
écologistes qui disent que ce projet est
une aberration écologique
mais ce n'est pas une aberration
écologique c'est nous n'avons pas
d'autres solutions pour désenclaver ce
territoire mais vous vous rendez compte
quand même que c'est 140000 habitants
qui sont à plus d'une heure et quart de
Toulouse c'est à dire qu'il y a moins de
création d'emplois il y a un taux de
pauvreté plus élevé moi je voudrais
qu'on parle des gens allez vous balader
à Castres ou Amazon vous allez voir que
ce sont des territoires qui perdent de
la population où la misère elle suinte
et donc nous avons besoin de soutenir
les entreprises qui sont présentes et
nous avons besoin d'attirer de nouvelles
entreprises moi je veux stopper
permettre aux pollinisation je veux
arrêter que Toulouse s'engorge mais on a
besoin de moyen de communication pour
que les petites villes comme Castres
elles puissent se développer l'autoroute
c'est pas l'alpha al Omega mais c'est un
des moyennes nécessaires nous avons
réouvert un musée le musée Goya à
Castres nous implantons la région des
formations d'enseignement supérieur mais
nous avons besoin de mobilisation courte
avec différentes actions pour sortir les
gens de la misère et pour faire en sorte
qu'ils aient espoir dans l'avenir parce
que sinon c'est très bien que quand des
gens se sentent loin de tout quand ils
se sentent abandonnés et bien à ce
moment-là c'est l'extrême droite qui
gagne
un mot sur le budget d'abord sur
l'autonomie peut-être puisque parmi vos
demandes il y a accroître pardon la
décentralisation vous avez fait un livre
blanc l'année dernière à ce sujet ce
matin Emmanuel Macron est encore est-ce
que vous lui demandez de lancer le
processus d'autonomie dans l'île
oui tout à fait je ne ce que nous
demandons dans le Livre blanc des
régions de 2022 nous avons souhaité
qu'il y ait l'autonomie pour l'accord et
j'espère que ce matin le président de la
République va faire des annonces fortes
nous avons un président de la région
Corse Gilles semeoni qui est volontaire
qui est responsable qui est fiable il
faut que le Président de la République
puisse conclure vraiment une avancée qui
soit forte pour l'accord c'est pour ses
habitants et vous demandez au-delà de la
Corse plus de décentralisation là aussi
vous attendez Elisabeth borne
nous avons une maturité politique en
France qui nous permet en effet d'avoir
plus d'autonomie je pense au territoire
d'outre-mer et je ne pensais en
particulier pour Mayotte où il n'y a
quasiment plus d'eau potable nous avons
besoin de pouvoir différencier les
actions entre les régions d'outre-mer
mais entre aussi les régions des
métropoles parce qu'une région qui a
quatre départements ce n'est pas la même
dynamique la même organisation qu'une
région qui en a 12 ou 13 donc nous
défendons vraiment qui puisse y avoir
plus d'autonomie dans le fait régional
et plus aussi de différenciation ce
n'est certainement pas d'aller vers
l'indépendantisme nous voulons rester
dans la République une indivisible mais
il y a besoin d'avoir de la souplesse
pour apporter des vraies solutions à nos
concitoyens nous nous voulons être dans
le fer nous voulons être dans la le
concret et amener des solutions sur la
question budgétaire parce qu'évidemment
elle est importante vous dites que la
dynamique de la TVA n'est pas suffisante
pour vous permettre de compenser vos
coûts est-ce que vous attendez là-dessus
des annonces d'Élisabeth borne est-ce
que vous lui demandez de vous accorder
une nouvelle enveloppe
tout d'abord on va rappeler la réalité
quand je vois le ministre des comptes
publics qui indique que la dynamique de
la TVA est supérieure à la dynamique de
l'inflation c'est faux en 2023 pour les
régions nous avons 1,3 milliards d'euros
de dépenses supplémentaires pour
l'électricité pour les carburants et la
dynamique de la TVA elle n'est que de
600 millions d'euros c'est un
différentiel de 700 millions les régions
nous avons été les plus accompagnantes
des politiques gouvernementales pour la
relance suite au covid et au confinement
et c'est nous qui sommes le plus
pénalisés par la question de l'inflation
parce qu'il y a la conjugaison et de
l'électricité et du prix du carburant
donc c'est incroyable de penser qu'on
est en train d'asphyxier les régions
alors que le couple est en région est
absolument indispensable pour atteindre
les objectifs de la transition
écologique de la souveraineté et puis
tout simplement de lutter contre les
inégalités qui ne font que ça croître du
coup qu'est-ce que vous demandez à
Elisabeth borne une dotation
exceptionnelle
tout d'abord nous demandons d'avoir en
fait des dotations qui soient au même
niveau que l'année dernière parce que
dans ce projet de la finance il y a une
baisse de près de 150 millions d'euros
et ensuite nous demandons qu'il y ait
une compensation de l'inflation et c'est
pourquoi nous avons demandé plus de 350
millions qui seront fléchés vers des
investissements divers que ça soit pour
la rénovation énergétique des lycées des
bâtiments ou que ça soit pour les
mobilités un dernier mot sur ce sujet
qui concerne évidemment les Français
l'inflation l'augmentation des prix et
notamment du carburant Emmanuel Macron a
promis un chèque ciblé pour les Français
les plus modestes qui ont besoin de leur
voiture pour aller travailler vous
saluer ce coup de pouce
oui parce que de nombreux Français ont
absolument besoin de la voiture je suis
président de la Région
Occitanie on développe beaucoup le train
c'est plus de 13 millions de billets à 1
euro chaque année mais pour autant il y
a des territoires où la seule solution
c'est la voiture et moi je ne veux pas
la stigmatisation de ces populations et
donc il est absolument indispensable de
pouvoir les aider quand vous pensez
qu'un plein c'est 100 euros et que
souvent ces habitants de territoire
ruraux ou de montagne ils ont besoin de
trois quatre plein dans le mois vous
vous rendez compte un budget qui entre
350 et 400 euros par mois ça peut
représenter un tiers du salaire donc il
y a une asphyxie il y a une pauvreté qui
est en train d'éclater et il faut avoir
des actions pour les plus modestes on va
parler politique on va parler du Parti
socialiste maintenant Carole Delga
d'abord un mot sur ce qui s'est passé au
Sénat cette semaine puisque Patrick
canaire qui est sur votre ligne a été
réélu président du groupe socialiste
contre Eric et rouge qui était soutenu
par Olivier Faure qui est plutôt sur une
ligne pro Nupe est-ce que vous avez vu
dans la réélection de Patrick kaner la
défaite d'Olivier Faure
surtout ce que j'ai vu dans la réaction
de Patrick Kanner c'est la
reconnaissance du travail sérieux de la
capacité de fédérer de Patrick et je
suis très heureuse qui soit de nouveau
président du groupe socialiste au Sénat
vous n'avez pas vu un message des
sénateurs socialistes envers la ligne de
Livier fort
ça ce sont des débats qu'on a entre nous
vous savez franchement les Français moi
de la nupinement il ne m'en parle pas ce
sont des débats qui sont très parisiens
surtout les élus
locaux les élus locaux ceux qui voient
ce qu'il voit c'est le désespoir des
Français la pauvreté qui grandit les
difficultés pour pouvoir s'alimenter ce
qui voit c'est des femmes et des hommes
qui parfois se prive d'un ou deux repas
dans la semaine qui ont du mal à
financer tous les efforts liés à la
rentrée scolaire donc franchement les EU
locaux et ils sont dans le réel donc
toutes ces histoires politiciennes de
tractations ça c'est au sein de
l'Assemblée nationale dont on ne fait
que parler que de la que de la nupaisse
moi ce que je souhaite aussi
et quel travail vous organisez ce
week-end vous vos rencontres de gauche
de la gauche Abraham c'est dans l'Aude
qui seront les personnalités présentes
est-ce qu'il y aura est-ce qu'il y aura
des la France insoumise
ce sont des rencontres populaires voilà
ce Abraham c'est les rencontres de la
gauche Brahm c'est un petit village de
3500 habitants dans l'Aude moi je veux
envoyer un message au classement
populaire dans les territoires ruraux
pour leur dire oui on sait travailler
ensemble on amène des vrais solutions on
n'est pas dans l'invective on n'est pas
dans l'affrontement on est cette gauche
populaire cette gauche qui est
bienveillante cette gauche qui vous
donne un espoir et donc tout le monde
est bienvenu et j'ai invité l'ensemble
des forces de la gauche mais même
l'ensemble des forces citoyennes il n'y
a pas de sectarisme on doit avoir
mobilisé forte pour stopper bien sûr
laissez-moi finir on doit avoir une
mobilisation forte pour pouvoir stopper
ces petites musiques de division donc on
a Karima Delhi qui va représenter les
écologistes on a Yann brossa qui va
présenter les communistes j'avais invité
manuel Bompard il a indiqué qu'il
n'était pas disponible il y aura bien
entendu aussi des radicaux de gauche il
y aura des chefs d'entreprise il y aura
aussi des représentants syndicaux voilà
ce sont des forces vives qui ont envie
de travailler ensemble qui ont envie
d'avoir une énergie positive et de
stopper vraiment ce cette ambiance qui
est délétère où on est tout le temps
dans les attaques ce que nous demande
les Français c'est pas de la violence
sont pas des des mots qui sont agressifs
ce qui nous demande c'est des solutions
aux Français ils sont il y aura pas
Olivier fort si on a bien compris est-ce
que vous pensez que le parti socialiste
à l'heure actuelle sous la conduite
d'Olivier Faure répond suffisamment aux
préoccupations des Français dont vous
parlez
a été invité il a répondu qu'il était
sur une autre manifestation et donc il y
aura voilà d'autres socialistes qui
n'avaient pas la même opinion que moi
sur l'Union pour les législatives c'est
les socialistes dans toute leur
diversité mais dans l'unité c'est la
gauche dans toute sa diversité et puis
surtout c'est la force citoyenne qui
veut de vrai transformations et qui en
ont assez d'être dans un climat à
exacerber et qui veulent travailler
travailler pour les gens parce que ce
que nous demande en effet le peuple
c'est d'avoir un travail de valeur qui
donne de la dignité c'est d'avoir aussi
des services publics et c'est de pouvoir
vivre dignement grâce aux revenus du
travail mais cette gauche vous
n'organisez pas ces rencontres pour rien
Carole delgas c'est que vous voulez
incarner cette gauche dont vous parlez
vous voulez l'incarner jusqu'où quels
sont vos ambitions
clairement l'heure n'est pas aux
ambitions personnelles ce serait quand
même complètement fou de ne pas avoir
une vision réelle de l'état du pays
regardez le livre de Thomas picetti et
de Julia kg qu'est-ce qui disent qu'il y
a un sentiment d'abandon un sentiment
d'abandon de la population bien moins le
message que je veux faire passer au
peuple se dire oui on est là et on bosse
pour vous et on vous emmène des
solutions en Occitanie la région elle
fournit les manuels scolaires elle
fournit les ordinateurs le transport
scolaire est gratuit en Occitanie ou une
aide les entreprises aussi bien le
boulanger pour s'installer dans un
village 500 habitants que la start-up
qui va avoir une innovation
révolutionnaire dans les traitements
médicaux c'est cela la réalité et en
Occitanie vous voulez incarner un autre
parti social des billets à 1 euro ce que
je veux c'est qu'il y ait une gauche
populaire qui puisse répondre aux
aspirations il faut arrêter la gauche de
l'invective la gauche de la violence
verbale il faut être au service du
peuple et arrêter de parler de sexuels
d'avoir une ambition aujourd'hui en 2027
c'est n'importe quoi d'avoir une
ambition justement pour 2027 voilà de
dire qu'en 2023 on se projette pour une
ambition personnelle pour 2027 mais
c'est n'importe quoi on n'est pas
conscient de la réalité du pays qui
c'est qui est en dynamique politique
aujourd'hui c'est l'extrême droite c'est
le rassemblement national et de mon
moins mon combat c'est d'avoir une
victoire de la gauche pour les
prochaines échéances que ça soit les
municipales ou que ça soit les
présidentielles et la question de celle
ou de celui qui portera ce message elles
viendra plus tard il faut bosser il faut
faire des propositions il faut être une
équipe de toute la gauche une victoire
de toute la gauche ou est-ce qu'à un
moment il va falloir dire non à la
France insoumise
ce qu'il faut c'est une victoire de la
France voyez c'est ça qu'il faut il faut
une victoire des Françaises et des
Français pour que de nouveau les
Françaises et les Français y croient à
la politique il ce qu'il faut c'est une
victoire d'un élan populaire et donc à
ce moment-là c'est toute seule et tout
ce qui veulent les lampes populaires et
qui veulent en effet avoir des vrais
politiques de gauche qui transforment la
vidéo qui luttent contre les inégalités
et qui permettent vraiment de donner un
vrai espoir et la possibilité à chacun
de choisir son destin c'est ça la gauche
la lutte contre les inégalités et être
libre de sa vie libre de son destin
merci Carole Helga merci beaucoup
d'avoir été avec nous depuis Saint-Malo
ou se tient le Congrès des régions de
France on suivra en direct sur Public
Sénat la clôture de ce congrès avec
votre discours mais également les
discours de Gérard Larcher et
d'Elisabeth borne évidemment la première
ministre très attendue merci beaucoup
Carole Delga